if you're a man  for any man in this room if I was to sit  here and break down a woman so for  example  I would say she's  she's very very caring she loves her  career yeah like she's very very driven  she's got loads of friends around her  that love and respect to her family  adores and pieces Highly Educated what  is every single man in this room  thinking right now  if I was to describe a woman and start  off and purely lay out those  um attributes or traits or her history  right what what for any guy in here or  any guy listening what question do you  have in mind what's the first question  you have what does she look like thank  you very much